need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something greater
inside you as well
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
add something so get ready to control
your emotions be a good leader and stop
trading your days for dollars with
jockle willing and my take on his top
ten rules a success vol 10 to help you
get the belief that you need
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't trade your days for dollars I
struggle with the daily grind trading
days for dollars but you helped me make
it happen
yeah and my comment was like okay well
thank you I guess
because I hope at the same time that
you're grinding that you're trading that
your I hope that you're not trading days
for dollars long term because long term
that's a losing proposition right if
you're grinding and it's not doing
something you want to do if it's a grind
that you can't embrace then you gotta
find a way out of that right you got to
find you can't Trey you don't want to
trade days for dollars because dollars
don't mean anything days all you got so
you gotta find a way out now this does
not mean you need to be rash about it
this doesn't mean tomorrow you walk you
know look through this job anymore I'm
out and now you're broke no don't be
rash and don't throw the baby out with
the bathwater but do come up with a
long-term plan about what you want to do
how you want to do it where you want to
do it and this might take one year or
two years or five years it might take
five years to get to where you want to
be that's okay that's fine
it's it's actually kind of cool when
you're grinding right now because you
know there's something that you're
working towards in the long run that's
actually awesome
so but but you gotta have an exit
strategy
you gotta have an exit strategy you got
a plan and figure out how much money
it's gonna take and what are you gonna
do you're gonna work two jobs I'm gonna
save all my money right now I'm gonna
invest here then pay off my mortgage
whatever is your gonna do so that you
can get yourself in a position where you
actually enjoy doing what you're doing
that's what you want
rule number two know how to play the
game if I tell you echo hey echo I want
you to do this mission I want you to do
this way take your platoon and go do it
and you disagree with what I'm telling
you yeah and you just say hey boss I
don't want to do it that way and I said
hey you shut up and do what I told you
to do and you go you know what you can
fire me but I'm not doing it I go okay
fine you're fired and I get knucklehead
over here who's a yes-man it comes in
and I tell him to go do the mission the
way I tell him to do it and he goes and
doesn't gets everyone killed mm-hmm
would it have been better off if you
said okay boss I get it I I'll do it
your way here's some things I'd really
like to not do and you go no I said no
shut up and then you take your guys you
mitigate everything that you can
actually there's an example of this in
Band of Brothers where major winners is
being told hey send a reconnaissance
element across the river again tonight
mm-hmm and he doesn't want to do it the
the war is almost over they had taken
some casualties I think the night before
when they did the same type of operation
and he just says god it boss and then
the guys go and they sit in the they
pretend to go out but they really just
sit in the basement of a building on
their side of the river
mm-hm and then later on they say up we
went we came back we didn't find
anything okay cool
there's a perfect example mm-hmm imagine
if major winners winners was like we're
not doing it and now you're getting an
ego contest with the colonel it was like
oh yes you are no we're not okay fine
you're fired
let me get knucklehead over here who's
gonna do what I told him to do who's a
total yes-man and now we take that risk
and guys get killed so so who is it bet
there's a there's winners played the
game he played the game so he could
still have that influence and power and
still protect his guys
ya can get complex yeah it's it's very
that's why the leadership is hard yes
that's it's weird though because when
you say it's complex when you say
leadership is hard at the same time like
you if you're a principled human being
and you have principles and you know
what's right and you're doing the right
thing for the right reason the decisions
are actually usually a little easier
clearly clearer yeah it might not be
easy but they're clearer like I know
what I'm supposed to do here yeah I got
it yeah I got I'm gonna figure this one
out rule number three work with others
and it's easy to justify yourself you
know like you're you're let's say okay
I'm real good at fitness you know the
biggest guru and I go around and then I
see out I know I go to the store go to
some party
and I see this other guy who's like
socially he's just a hundred percent
everyone likes me such a nice
charismatic guy makes a lot of money you
know and all this stuff but he's not in
that good of shape or I don't know he
smokes and whatever you know it's easy I
think a lot of people it feels like it's
easy to justify well that guy's in bad
shape so who cares
I don't want any of that I wouldn't want
all the money you know all this stuff it
seems like and you know what the other
guy's saying yeah you might be in good
shape guess what yeah
nice Toyota Corolla you're driving he's
all negative on it yeah yeah yeah so
both those guys should Ishould instead
of saying hey you know what they should
do walk up and be like hey man you know
what I notice you're pretty successful
financially I would like to get in the
game with you a little bit and and learn
from you about that any other guy should
say to him well you know what it looks
like you're in pretty good fitness
levels I would like to get in the game
with that let's work together and
improve ourselves and go out and kick
ass and dominate are you in I'm in let's
do this instead what does a normal
person do they do exactly what you said
justify criticize cut people down
instead of building them up yeah and
what you have to be careful of if I was
to go to you and say hey you know echo I
got a lot of money I can tell you don't
have a lot I'll help you out
that's that can be offensive to some
people yeah did you think do you think
you are
I'm gonna need your help money ya think
I'm worried about money when I got abs
like geez you know so what we have to do
is instead of if you if I came to you
and said echo dude I want abs like you
got sir
can you help me get in the game and then
we formed a little relationship and now
I say to you man so what's your what's
your main income stream dude you know
what are you doing
and you say well you know I got these
two clients you got a website no not
really
well why don't you have a website you
got any social media to advertise all
you know and we go though that road and
we hold up we take care of each other so
we want to do as people yeah kind of
like you ever seen the guys who go they
see like a football player or something
like I kick his ass though you know you
know that King guy can always like some
success and I kick his ass though yeah
yeah then well I've told the story
before in the SEAL Teams it's aha
knowing no one is good although if a guy
like we have guys in the SEAL Teams that
are literally you know world-class
athletes in whatever world-class
triathlete world-class sailor
world-class whatever and so oh you owe
your your world cost triathlete oh yeah
that guy's really good triathlete that's
cool he's a really bad job someone's
gonna chime in and cut him down yeah
rule number four control your emotions
there are many times in life in the
world where showing your emotions are
gonna have a negative impact on your
situation your you give up the takedown
in jiu-jitsu competition mm-hmm and you
show it in your face that person just
thinks that's proved you right you don't
show any emotion their boss tells you
getting stuck with the underperforming
team show any emotion right don't don't
oh man mmm don't do that but hey what
about this there's a good one boss is
giving you feedback that you don't agree
with roll your eyes I mean the
the heavy sigh the punch teeth as you're
trying to listen what this purse you can
be respecting he's telling you what's
that gonna get you not gonna get you
anything
then showing that negative emotion there
you need to keep normal face in that
situation your kids doing something
that's annoying it's try to test your
patience they're just trying to piss you
off don't let them keep it in check
get told to go to the other line in DMV
after you've been waiting for an hour
one don't freak out don't show any
motions got it yeah here's here's
another one we already talked about this
one your friends are poked in front of
you because you missed a shot at the
range or you got lost on a land
navigation course or whatever get all
mad don't get frustrated
don't show any emotion you know they
make fun of your haircut they make fun
of your accent they make fun or whatever
don't show emotions don't freak out
that's the other balance now there are
also times where you might have to force
yourself to show some emotion just to
get the point across right your kid
hasn't listened to you after five or six
violations hmm you might have to show
some anger or they'd or they do
something that's gonna get him hurt
right you've got to show some emotion so
that they realize that was real but
flying off the temper in lieu the flying
off the handle and losing your tempers
almost never does you any good so yeah
you have to be balanced in order to be
balanced you have to be in control and
in order be in control you have to
detach from your emotion so you can
control your emotions and not let your
emotions control you also if you want to
have more confidence checking my 254
series they're free the links to join
are in the description below people want
to know how to stop the laziness and
they will know how to stop the
procrastination and I looked at him and
I said I'm not a brand I'm a person a
self discipline it comes from the self
it comes from you rule number five have
a clear purpose
how important is purpose reason a cause
in being successful clearly purpose and
reason
cause are extremely important this is
this is the why of your actions this is
knowing why you're doing what you're
doing this is the commander's intent and
so you you absolutely that absolutely
czar important if you don't know why
you're doing something well then let me
ask you a question why are you doing
something it does it's it's very clear
it's very simple to understand
so yeah you got to know if you don't
know why you're doing something then
what were you gonna do when you hit an
obstacle you're gonna stop what do you
what what adaptations are you gonna make
when things go wrong to overcome them
you're not gonna make any cuz you don't
know why you're doing it yeah so if you
have no reason if you have no reason for
doing something you're not gonna do it
so you gotta have a long-term goal we
gotta understand the underlying purpose
of what you're doing
rule number six be a good leader you
know who you have control over you you
know if control you don't have control
over your nine-year-old kid you might
think you do but you don't you got to
make you know if control over your wife
to just make her you know get in the
game mmm oh you wanted you want to stay
on the program you want to cook whatever
14 chicken breasts on a Sunday night so
you have to a day during the week honey
make it happen no honey don't make that
happen if you are a good leader and you
explain what your goals are and you get
her on board with the program mmm then
yeah guess what she's doing on Sunday
night helping you cook some chicken
breast for the week yeah but this is
just like anything else man this is just
like any other leadership situation you
want to blame the team when something's
going wrong that's not gonna get you a
solution you need to take ownership of
the problem you need to get the problem
solved and when I say get the problem
solved
you're you this doesn't mean impose your
will on the team that means you need to
leave the team and there's a big
difference rule number seven don't put
all your eggs in one basket
don't put a hundred percent of your
effort into one area because eventually
it will take you you won't have anything
else and by the way if you
all your you know if you put all your
all your eggs in the basket of
intellectual power now you're unhealthy
and you die right that doesn't you know
I don't care how smart you are you can't
do 2+2 when you're dead so don't put all
your focus a hundred percent into one
area
don't become unbalanced in your
disciplines spread it around and hold
the line rule number eight surround
yourself with high performers what's the
best approach to managing people that
outperform you I think this is a simple
question as well what you do in this
situation is you give them all the
support you can and let them run I'm
happy if someone's outperform me that's
great you know what else I'll do try and
learn from them and see what they're
doing
try and spread the word if I'm gonna
leadership position and someone's doing
outperforming everyone great how can we
take that how can we teach to everyone
else how can I give them support so you
can run even faster this is no factory
to me I love it you should be
surrounding the more people you can
bring on your team that helped perform
you the better you're gonna do rule
number nine learn how to hire good
people everybody wants them to know who
to hire and what I look for and
obviously I look for someone that's
humble and I look for someone that's
balanced and really you know it's one of
those things where as much as you can
before you hire someone get to know them
and the device we give people national
in front all the time when they're
looking hire someone as we say look if
you can hire them temporarily bring them
on as a contractor for 90 days you have
to see them in the environment that
they're actually going into they're
gonna be working in before you know what
they're really gonna like because it's
just like going through the screen
people like crazy to go into seal
training and it they can't tell who's
gonna make it and who's not gonna make
it they just can't tell and they you
work with people in the SEAL Teams and
you think you know what they're gonna be
like when you're going to combat but you
just can't tell you can have a decent
idea but you just can't tell and so if
you get the opportunity or the best way
to do it is try and bring people on
board
a temporary manner so you get to know
them better and then once you know them
you can either hire them or you can get
rid of them easily and rule number 10
the last only for a very special bonus
clip is have a back-up plan when I
retired from the Navy and got out and
started the consulting business working
and one of my risk-averse friends that
was staying in the military for its its
welfare program write it so it's a
paycheck right Andi the guy wasn't you
know he wasn't all fired up anymore but
he was in and so he had a mortgage to
pay and kids to feed so he's just
staying in and he kind of looked at me
when I was getting out and I said yeah
man I got bills to pay too but I'm gonna
go and get after it somehow and he said
what are you gonna do if it if it you
know if the business doesn't work and
you end up with me you know you're gonna
come back in and what are you gonna do
you won't be able to get back in baba
baba and I said bro worst-case scenario
everything goes to hell
guess what I'm gonna be doing I have an
RV I will be in my RV with my family
we'll be driving up and down the coast
of California raiding jujitsu schools
and training and I'll be surfing it's
all good and it won't cost me barely
anything do that my retirement cover
will be good to go
you got a back-up plan like that that
attitude for me freed me yeah a
worst-case scenario I lose everything
cool I still have my RV it's paid for
yeah we're good yeah totally
now I have a special bonus clip from
Jocko and how to find balance that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking some action here we go
question number one what is your backup
plan number two who is the next good
hire that you need to bring on board and
number three what is being a good leader
look like to you now if you liked this
video and you're gonna take some action
right after it give me a hashtag believe
down in the comments below
for a new entrepreneur or someone new to
a leadership position who is meeting
with their employees or direct report or
direct reports for the first time what
are some key things to address during
that initial conversation as soon as you
meet someone that's going to be working
for you you're immediately making
impression so we want to make a good
impression
we also don't want to go okay it's a
it's a dichotomy because you're
immediately building a relationship with
them but you can't go overboard and be
all buddy-buddy with them that's why I
followed the hackworth model and I
actually took that to the next level
Hackworth wouldn't like laugh and joke
around with the troops for six weeks I
upped that to eight weeks because I'm a
little bit more hard force yeah so you
but but one thing that's good out of the
gate is put out some brief general
guidelines like some some of the most
broad guidance that you can possibly
give which is hey look here's what's
important to me we're going to do a
great job we're gonna work hard and this
is our mission and this is what we're
gonna focus on and that's it you don't
need to come out of the gate trying to
show everyone that you're the man you
don't need to do that
guess what you're the boss you actually
de facto are the man so don't run around
and try and prove yourself out of the
gate get to know them let that
relationship build over time and that's
we're gonna end up in the best situation
and if you want more Jocko willing
motivation check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
disappear
[Music]
it's an eighth internal force
[Applause]
oh sure of course